you have bro I did so slouch down
disrespectful what are you doing here my
core dude it's not a place to work I
don't normally [ __ ] go this long
without taking care of my [ __ ] core
okay well so I'm just gonna chill for a
little bit this is dude by the way all
right you know I get it yeah but it's so
annoying how many [ __ ] views I get on
your [ __ ] podcast it's not bad
flexibility my legs won't ghost yeah I
have really good flexibility you can do
that and I can can you could you ever
have yeah yeah so it's so you can do
physically I can do better do it now now
right so you're better at [ __ ]
yourself got you that you're better at
[ __ ] yourself you're better at
losing your hair is not I'm worried
because the Samson effect will take full
full bore which is well if you lose your
hair we all know what happened to the
old career I'm gonna shave desert trust
me man I want to [ __ ] shave my head
yeah but then nah I'm gonna get beefy
enough to where I'm gonna shave my head
and it's gonna be a whole different
ballgame my baby oh oh yeah you want to
talk about traps dude I'm gonna do
steroids I don't give a [ __ ] I will do
if I lose my hair I'll do steroids and
I'll make a gap in my teeth I don't give
a [ __ ] oh oh you think
oh oh hi steroids nice to meet you you
think you're going to space my teeth out
no no no no no no no no no no no I'm
gonna take a [ __ ] penny and I'm gonna
[ __ ] hammer that [ __ ] up in there
I'll beat you to it you [ __ ] nice guy
I'll beat you to it you nice guy
[Music]
steroids nab not so aggressive
I went from me it's super you're not
losing right I mean is he a little bit
but everyone does a little bit when you
get older
don't get on the old uh pshh yeah
because you gotta salvage it before it
yeah he's really getting thin I'm sorry
I am NOT your neck is getting it's
losing its character its losing his
shape my whole family has hair man they
never lost their hair I'm gonna pop says
get here yeah yeah but you're not my
dad's went back a little bit but it's
all [ __ ] your character so the middle
doesn't yeah I'm good I'm good it'll
goes that you you drop middle goes yeah
mines not give more hair than you had
yeah I take propecia okay well you're on
it right now be yeah that him stuff I
actually think I have more hair than I
did about [ __ ] two years ago because
I've been taking decision wrong have
been taking propecia why wouldn't you
yeah I mean it's just a case you know
dude I can't because I'm worried it's
gonna run into my eyebrows well yeah you
don't have much to worry about do you
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]